- Hey, hey, welcome to Every Damn Day.
We're gonna be dedicating
our entire episode
to talking about how Banksy
just redid the American flag.
Guys, what do we think?
(groans)
- Cool.
- I guess.
- Okay.
- Cool.
- Whatever.
- Okay, I guess those
are all of our thoughts,
so the show is done now.
Like, comment, and subscribe.
- Cut!
Guys, what the hell?
This is a discussion show.
You need opinions, and personality,
and a passion for the issues,
not in an annoying way,
like Ryan, obviously.
But, can we pull something together?
Like 60 Minutes, but for memes.
- Yeah.
- Yeah?
- Sure.
(upbeat music)
- Okay gang, so, you all
need to develop personalities
because you are boring and unrelatable.
To do that, why don't we
brainstorm some character traits
for each of you that we can
use to write fun, new segments?
Sound good?
- Oh, I have one.
Ryan, you resemble a sickly bird
that turned into a sicker human,
so, what if we did a segment called,
Ryan eats worms on camera?
(hands clap)
- Good, good,
I like that a lot, that's really great!
How about Natasha?
- Hm, what if we did something about
how Natasha's become a really good actor,
because she has no personality of her own
and is hiding the fact
that she's a sociopath?
(all laughing)
(Natasha cackles)
What, come on!
You guys crack me up, me normal.
- This is great, really good stuff.
Let's keep it going, how 'bout Chris?
- Well, Chris is a loser
conspiracy theorist
who watches Illuminati
listicles on YouTube, so--
- No I don't!
- You're watching a video called,
10 Reasons Stuart Little is Illuminati.
- I mean, but, how he get
those clothes, though?
- And Hannah, you were kinda mean to me
from the start and everyone in the office
thinks you're an asshole,
so let's just do a segment about that.
- Ouch, that stings.
But without honesty there
isn't personal growth.
- Hey, what's up guys?
It's me, Roy Wood, Jr., Daily Show,
just wanted to pop in real quick,
let you know that you're
all deeply flawed.
'Cept for Jordy Pizza here.
He's my best friend.
- Thanks, Roy Wood, Jr.
See ya at lunch?
- I'm buyin'.
(hands slapping)
- Get it together.
- And my character trait is,
I'm kinda the funny one in the group,
so let's just roll with that.
- Ha, ha!
Sounds good, and truthful.
In fact, I just got an
email from the execs
that said Jordan is getting his own show!
Three cheers for Jordan!
Yay!
(cheers)
(triumphant music)
- [Everyone] Jordan, Jordy, Jordan.
(bright piano music)
- Then we fade out, the end.
(clapping)
Woo!
Really great table read, guys, like bravo!
- You wrote a script that ends
with you getting your own show?
- You really think you're the, funny one?
- Yeah, all of your
character traits you wrote
were just criticisms of everyone else.
- That's not my fault.
I just couldn't think of
anything negative about myself.
- I've got an idea.
Why don't we list a
few of Jordan's traits?
- Well, you don't take criticism well,
and you get really defensive.
- That's not (bleep) true, you bitch!
- Plus your mustache look
like 15 ants died on your lip.
(chuckles)
- You dress like a Mr. Rogers
that no one would mourn.
And Mr. Rogers is my taxidermist.
- I bet you can only
get your girlfriend wet
with your tears.
- Who told you that?
(laughing)
- (cackles) That's funny as hell, Hannah.
(hands slapping) That's all right, my dog.
I don't know you, Jordan.
And you're not my friend. (spits)
- Okay, great work, lots of good ideas.
- I guess they're not gonna use my script.
Or will they?
(upbeat instrumental music)